hey there welcome to fireside bookstore
and thank you all for coming today I'm
Dianne Dickerson co-owner of the
bookstore we're delighted to have you
all here today to support Tom Tucker he
was here eight years ago to sign copies
of his young adult book called brain
storms today we are pleased to welcome
him back for his new book bolt of fate
Benjamin Franklin and his kite hoax
which is now in its second printing mr.
Tucker has had many positive reviews and
magazines and newspapers including
reviews in Forbes The New Yorker the
Christian Science Monitor and new
science magazines
mr. Tucker will read from his book then
take questions from the audience and
then sign books and if you don't mind if
you'll signal that you want to ask a
question so that we can have the
microphone on you before you ask your
question so we can hear you
that's all and thank you please welcome
Tom Tucker oh thank you all very much
for coming on I would like to thank give
it out about three things to start with
I'd like to thank this wonderful book
store fireside books it's just a
wonderful place I would also like to
thank isothermal it's a it's a great
campus and there are many people here
from it and I'm grateful to work there
and in addition I especially need to
thank my wife Diane she herself is a
dancer choreographer and wonderful
writer who helped me in many ways on
this project in research and editorial
and also we went out behind the
foundation building in the parking lot
there and flew a replica
eighteenth-century kite as part of some
of the experimenting that when I
in the last couple years I'd like to
call Diane forward to recognize her
place Ben Franklin came to live with us
about five years ago he was right at the
dinner table he was under the dinner
table or right behind Tom's left
shoulder he was mentioned so many times
I knew he lived with us then Ben
Franklin became our friend we talked for
hours about him laughs over him and
consider how he was like Tom's dad that
he was brought up with no education and
had a rough start then the moment came
in London when we were given his
handwritten letters and Tom trembled
with delight at how they were right
they're not under glass but right in
front of him I say at sharing the odd
wonder and began signing my letters your
humble and devoted servant as Ben did
with boring hours of searching for a
needle in a haystack on the computer and
many lunches in Tom's office getting
orders for the day
and interviewing teachers for
translation and help and with reading
and reading and more reading marking the
margins for the housewives view this
book has become another child with a
life of its own and this time Tom gave
birth and I assisted this bit book has
meant hours of not speaking to time
leaving him to concentrate it has meant
not having people over not having
parties it meant listening beyond
understanding at times and reading deep
into the night for three months from
11:30 to 2:00 in the morning going to
get paper at 3:00 am putting chapters
down driving him to the post office and
putting him to bed after he got it in
the mail and the things I got was a
voice from upstairs saying come on up
here and then there would be a swish
swish shuffling sound and he would give
me an electric kiss which is you you go
on your socks around on the rug until
you get a spot
work and then you you kiss there was
electrical excitement for me it meant
learning new things how to do research
it how to edit I learned to talk to
learning authors in England I learned to
email scientists and gather information
and I learned that the best way to reach
a man is still through his stomach when
I shared with a scholar that how good
the food was in the Royal science the
Royal Society library cafeteria I fail
to learn how to remain silent which is
one of Ben Franklin's greatest traits
and even though I was under strict
instructions not to talk and even though
I tried as hard as I could I had some
good times and some days that things
would just spill out once going upstairs
to find something for time in his files
I was really odd at how extensive and
large they were other times when I'd sit
in our living room and hear him pacing
upstairs I knew he was thinking in order
to write and I'd beg god I wouldn't end
up stark raving mad like Ingrid Bergman
as she listened to her husband paced
back and forward in Gaslight other times
I thought I'd already gone over the edge
when I would tell my mother all about
this part of our lives and she would say
back what book
my main role I felt was to listen and I
did this as well as God enabled me to do
it to listen and to continue to love
something which I really fell in love
with when I first read the proposal I am
very proud of time today and I'm
grateful now that the huge part of our
life that we nurtured for three years
and which I wasn't supposed to talk
about for two years is now being talked
about with pleasure all over the country
and I'm glad the secret is out I stood
and held the picture frame to help him
fly his kite and I believe Benjamin
Franklin is still alive under our bed
and I know Tom's book bolt of fate is
beautifully written and I've given
thanks to God for all that it has meant
to both of us and I hope that you will
all take it home with you
[Applause]
does this sound like a husband who got
in trouble with his wife over his
project it does Benjamin Franklin's
electric kite is something every school
child in America grows up with and
learns about most of them know that he
flew this kite during a thunderstorm in
1752 it arguably the kite demonstration
is the most famous experiment in the
history of science certainly no American
experiment has been recorded more often
in heart and a little factoid it's the
only scientific experiment ever printed
on US currency but when I began to look
into the story of Franklin's kite I some
questions began to arise before I get
there let me just give you a little
background in case some of you are fuzzy
because I do run into people that get
fuzzy over Benjamin's kite what he was
doing was this in the 1740s there was a
wave of electrical and sperimentale in
fact it became a great fashion not just
and this was a world in which you had
both scientists and party animals at the
same time shoulder-to-shoulder in a
sense science threw a party for all of
England and much of the continent in the
1740s these parties involve people of
rank they involve kings they involve
celebrated beauties they involved
intellectuals and also a few tradesmen
who had great manual skill and kind of
shrewd insight into how to produce
electricity what was the electricity
they looked at it was really static
electricity what we know today when you
walk across a carpet on a winter day and
reach for that metal doorknob and get
snapped but in that time they had
devised these elaborate machines which
would crank up even bigger static
charges and it became the rage in fact
was I was especially fashionable with
young women and in London it was said it
put all the French dancing masters out
of business so Franklin himself enjoyed
women and he enjoyed parties so you can
see where the attraction partly came in
here ah about three years later comes
the kite experiment and that's this
famous event what was he doing well he
had asked himself was lightning a form
of electricity and actually it wasn't
that unusual a question you could
probably point to twenty or thirty men
who asked are suggested the same thing
in his time but he proposed that to find
out you take a kite and you floated up
there next to a storm cloud and see what
stuff came down the twine the
electrostatics as he told the tale later
I wasn't obviously it wasn't a lightning
bolt or there wouldn't have been a
Benjamin to tell but as he told it later
there was enough of an electrostatic
charge in the air that when he reached
for this kite which he had insulated by
a little strip of silk which acted as an
insulator with his knuckle he had a key
suspended from the twine and he got a
nice snap on the knuckle from it this
was the historic moment the more I
looked at this experiment I began to
wonder if it really happened because
there weren't very good
eighteenth-century sources for it it
didn't hold up in the way you would
expect something that was real to hold
up for several reasons first Franklin
and his announcement never actually said
he did it he said it was something that
might be done second Benjamin had a way
of experimenting a style he did other
electrical experiments brilliant ones
yeah he would always repeat them for a
close circle of friends this one was
apparently never repeated for a close
circle of friends
ah there were no witnesses to it the way
he told it usually experiments were done
at that time with witnesses you might
list their names in addition and his
friends usually repeated the experiment
for others in Philadelphia never
happened in France during the same time
variations on lightning experiments
afterwards were repeated and done again
and again before crowds but in
Philadelphia there was virtual silence
during this time and ever after just
about well nine years later one friend
of his flew quote an electric kite
uncook unquote on a clear dry day no
dummy he but I began to look into this I
wonder about really what happened
the real story starts back about
seventeen forty six when Benjamin
himself got into this wonderful party
scene he himself was boasting that he
had improved a party game called the
electric kiss by the way that was the
rage at some of these things ah he was
having a wonderful time but he was also
coming up with some brilliant hypotheses
about what was going on he wrote a
letter and sent it to the Royal Society
what happened there this letter went to
William Watson who was the foremost
electrical experimenter in this time
Watson later stood up with Franklin's
letter he read one experiment allowed
two pages and he said isn't this curious
because I already thought up this theory
there's no evidence that Watson did at
least if he did is not written on a
piece of paper it's purely an aural
claim and it's an odd one that it would
have come from the year before from a
man who himself off always wrote up his
experiments but had never gotten around
to this one
Franklin's in a second letter second
letter more brilliance he used his
plus/minus theory of electricity to
explain the Leyden jar this letter
simply vanished at the Royal Society not
printed as the other one hadn't been
printed this one not even read aloud but
what happened next according to the way
I view this sequence of events as he
sent some more experiments across the
Atlantic Ocean and what these were
really were not serious science but joke
insults which he sort of hurled across
the waters in the direction of the
people who were stonewalling him let me
give you a sample one of them led to the
electric kite in fact but let me give
you an earlier one Franklin suggested
that the people of the Royal Society
Electrify a picture of King George with
a removable crown on top and the game
would be to try to take and snatch the
elect the charged crown from the top of
the king's head Franklin's I'm sure
winked as he wrote these words on paper
he called the game the conspiracy this
game would have got you hanged of course
at that time but what it was I'm saying
was his way of saying to William Watson
well you said you thought up this other
experiment did you think of this one
before me too Watson never touched that
of course you're after Watson wrote some
very slidin remarks in a kind of
impersonal letter to Franklin that was
never published but Franklin got it and
just about within weeks after that
Benjamin sat down and sent another
experiment across the ocean he advised
that Watson or someone at the Royal
Society go out in an empty field during
a thunderstorm with a metal pole
extended up to this the heavens above
that this person could stand inside a
little enclosure called a sentry box
which in that time was a phone booth
sized little thing that sentry stood in
and the man's job would be if something
came down the rod to put his hand out
and get the charge deadly kind of
contraption and I don't think meant
seriously because Watson in London
prided himself on repeating all sorts of
things that came in and this man would
take it to the extreme there had been
reports that men had given themselves
halos by through electrical charges you
had to be a real religious mystic to go
this route but this word came to London
Watson actually managed to charge
himself to the point where his cheeks
tingle did as if spiders were crawling
over them victims of lightning strike
tell you that that's just what you feel
before the bolt comes down Watson went
to that extreme to get a hayloft he
never got a hammer but he never touched
the Sentry box experiment with a 10-foot
Paul nobody else in England ever touched
it with a ten-foot pole either neither
did Benjamin no one took it seriously
but here's where the story kicks in
Franklin's texts went abroad and over in
England two men two men in England both
of them were non-scientists and they
were sort of klutzes in that they had
been sent once afield to do some botany
experiments and hopelessly boggled the
effort but the man who sent them a power
at court named Buffon sent them to a
small village named Marley they were
also poor translators of English but
they had translated Benjamin's
suggestion for the Sentry box and they
set one up ah they did they did some
things that kept them safe for instance
nobody bothered to stick around all I
got charged but they did it a lightning
bolt came down afterwards someone came
up reached out and got a snap from the
pole I suppose it was the first case in
history of a man intentionally taking a
charge from
the heavens the news was brought back to
Paris overnight
Franklin became a celebrity the man who
had been an unknown was celebrated
everywhere the experiment was done in
Paris it was done before the king and
everywhere people echoed his name and
toasted him it was embarrassing in
England too at the time very
embarrassing of course for the English
and probably the some of the French knew
that but what happened is this maybe
four months later it takes time for
things to get in a newspaper and get
shipped home the news got to
Philadelphia abroad this had been called
the Philadelphia Experiment but there is
a question the question would have been
for Benjamin when is the Philadelphia
Experiment going to be done in
Philadelphia tough moment what happened
then in October of 1750 - in a kind of
bizarre brief newspaper announcement he
said oh I did this experiment four
months ago a variation on with a child's
toy with AK I just forgot to tell
anybody and he said there weren't any
witnesses although later to be fair to
him fourteen years afterwards he did say
there was a witness he claimed that his
illegitimate son William had been a
witness to this event but that was the
extent of it but it's my theory that
this is how the kite story arose in
writing bolt of fate I have looked into
it from many angles I've looked into it
in terms of the 18th century I've gone
out and flown a replica 18th century
kite there are a lot of issues that come
up a lot of the attention to my book has
come from chapter 14 long chapter I'm
not going to read today but it's all
about the kite and a lot of fun I think
in its own way but that's a whole issue
but I've given you a few of the initial
thoughts I had going in to this
but it's not something that just didn't
happen instead it's quite different
Franklin had to struggle and fight for
his reputation abroad it was done
originally to embarrass his rivals the
battle didn't end in 1752 there were
three major scientific academies and the
investigation of this new Wonder
electricity London where Franklin did
get some recognition finally they should
have recognized him back in 1746 that
took him long enough it took him about
till 1753 and there were two others I'm
really strong institutions one was the
Paris academy the other was the Berlin
Academy in 1764 at the Paris Academy
they formed a commission to look into
the kite story and awarded credit to
another man roma claiming he had
priority what about germany in germany
the president was a wonderful old
gentleman named euler if there's any
mathematicians in here maybe your ears
prick up at that people still know him
in the field of mathematics and he wrote
a wonderful survey of 18th century
science that became a best-seller called
letters to a German princess he had two
letters they really two chapters about
lightning science but if you look at him
never is the name of Franklin mentioned
once and I think on the American side of
the ocean we kind of blur that and we
say oh he was recognized everywhere but
it's sort of ostrich in the sand view of
what happened in fact it was a real push
for him to gain recognition even abroad
there were rivals and as my book
demonstrates often with comic tones in
the decades ahead he said himself too
shoring up and establishing the story of
himself as the investigator of lightning
science it came became crucially
important not just a science but to
world history in 1776 when Benjamin was
sent to Paris
this is one of those hinge moments in
history where science and politics come
together at this at this point back in
England later and back in England but at
this point Benjamin is sent to Paris
when he arrives there you really could
say the American Revolution is on the
ropes their treasury is empty their
armory is dry
men are not rien listing or else some
just vanishing from the ranks they don't
have coats New York is falling
Philadelphia is going to fall in a few
months they have no Navy out there on
the ocean the British are dominating the
sea Franklin got over perhaps quite
luckily twice they came after him the
British had brilliant intelligence they
knew he was going to France and they
tried to get him on twice they came near
but he arrived in France when Benjamin
showed up he's pretty old and he was
sickly he had gout he in fact he forced
them to let him ashore early and some
mud flats at our reef instead of taking
the regular longer journey to the port
and he showed up with this desperate
scenario on hand when he appeared he was
going to charm all of France this is one
of those moments of international
celebrity hard to understand afterwards
but it's a bit like Lindbergh coming
back to this country are the Beatles
arriving at Shea Stadium something about
Franklin coming to Paris clicked it
wasn't the things we know his
autobiography hadn't been published yet
they didn't know there was a publication
of poor Richard earlier that hadn't
gotten any recognition in France a year
and a half one would be published that
called him beau home Richard and turned
him into a a new world innocents age
that would be make him a celebrity it
has Bo home [ __ ] but the man who came
ashore was known for one thing he was
the lightning science he he had flown
the electric kite
this was the card he played at this very
desperate hinge moment in history also
he presented himself as an innocent at
that time in France it was fashionable
to think that in the new world there
existed primitive people who were very
much in touch with natural truth
Franklin wasn't all that innocent but he
didn't tell that he had silk coats he
had elaborate cuffs he had expensive
wigs but on the way to Paris jolting
along the back country roads there he
had a scalp affliction and was wearing a
little fur cap perhaps a there's various
theories about what it was but it was a
little fur cap and as people along the
way began to react to him something
clicked his first expense in France have
been 101 livers for wigs but he began to
toss them aside and go bareheaded or
where his little fur cap he didn't wear
silk he wore a plain brown coats at
times he didn't carry an elaborate
bejeweled cane which every gentleman
took pride in he carried a little thorn
crab crabapple cane and here he was the
innocent from the new world who had
plumbed the depths of electricity forget
that he lived for you know decade and a
half in London with the most
sophisticated associates in the world
Benjamin is my wife said was good at
keeping his mouth shut
one of his little mottos he passed on to
Thomas Jefferson late in life and
Jefferson and an interesting not often
looked at footnote to history talks
about how much it influenced him was
this bit of advice never contradict any
body
it wasn't advice to be a wimp in
Franklin's hands it was an incredibly
aggressive powerful tool one which
Jefferson himself later learned to use
in politics in France it was fashionable
to worship Quakers from America it was
thought these people were especially
sublime they thought Franklin was a
Quaker but Franklin never told them
otherwise he had invented bifocals
lasses when the young women tendered and
laughed at him because he had broken
glasses they thought oh that's his
natural economy that he talks about
impro Richard where he advises you to
save money Franklin didn't tell them
otherwise he was this marvelous poker
player a man who could carry a bluff all
the way perhaps in our time we don't
realize the extent of his hoaxing and
false presentations in the mid twentieth
century scholars began to count them
they number about at least forty-five to
fifty and bold of fate is a book that
suggests that among them should also be
placed the story of the electric kite
and I don't do this as debunking I have
great admiration for Franklin I think we
owe him and the electric kite if there
was one or the story of the electric
kite which I think more likely happened
I think we owe him and this story in
immense debt for the world we live in
I'd like to read you a few little
excerpts from the book
I keep thinking I should read you
arguments why I didn't fly the kite but
I'm not going to I'm going to instead
read you two descriptions whoops I got
the wrong book here let's see it oh did
I bring one up here oh thank you I would
like to read up a few short excerpts
where I entered there's Benjamin
Franklin in this book a bit of my vision
of him and also I introduce to you the
man who intercepted him at the Royal
Society because this is a really beneath
the old story is a much more interesting
adventure about how these two men's
lives intertwined they came into
opposition and the results of their
conflict had immense importance later on
in history
Benjamin Franklin came of age in the
print trade all week he lived with it
the clack of lead tight bits dropped
under the composing bar used by 18th
century printers and also the major
thump of the press issuing pages to be
sewn into him books and his brothers
weekly newspaper the current and broad
sides that would be tacked on to all the
pissing post in Boston during five years
of indenture the boy picked up a range
of skills it was a trade that in that
area required ideally quote a tolerable
genius for language and manual abilities
and fix-it skills as well this mix of
competencies would later help Franklin
when he entered electrical science and
it was also the trade that was to lay
the foundation for his fortune in
Pennsylvania on October 6 1773 however
Benjamin Franklin first appeared in the
streets of Philadelphia as a runaway
teenager he arrived as an escapee from
indenture he was 17 years old he must
have been attractive the runaway with a
moon face glowing hazel eyes and square
broad frame but he was also a sight
grimy from the hundred mile march and
coastal bay fairies dirty laundry
flapping from his pockets his financial
means diminished to a few coins there
was the wrinkle on his face scene later
in scores of portraits it was a sly
wrinkle descending from the corner of
his mouth revealing humor and drawl
generosity at once but as he walked the
strange streets he was depending on the
print trade to survive the next morning
Franklin presented himself at the shop
of Samuel Kaymer on Market Street
nothing about him suggested a journeyman
printer to KI Murr no black ink lying
Franklin's fingernails so you've been
away from the press of several weeks and
soused for 30 hours straight by
mid-atlantic seaboard gales
no stooped shoulders testified two years
has been over the press nothing about
his age was right so it was not
surprising when old Kimura held out the
composing stick a printer proved it the
boy took the stick and set to type
citing a line of poetry supplied by
Timur it was a literary dabbler franklin
must have been a formidable performance
he was hired on the spot
his Philadelphia entrance into his trade
had resolved into one simple question
can you do it it was the same in a way
in my mind it's the same entry he made
into electrical science no degrees no
club no society just the question can
you do it but let's look abroad to the
man who's going to intercept him
William Watson reigned over electrical
science in the english-speaking world
Watson an apothecary who kept a shop in
Aldersgate Street held a coveted
membership in the Royal Society had been
elected to its Board of members the
council it had been honoured in 1745
with a Copley medal in the spring Watson
would publish experiments and
observations on electricity a volume
that would become a best-seller race
through three printings immediately and
grace every fashionable coffee table in
West London and he was the man who would
steal Benjamin Franklin's theory
Watson is depicted in one surviving oil
portrait a middle-aged man with brown
eyes a large strong nose a small mouth
and stubborn jaws the small eyes gaze
levelly he must have been a measurer a
referee between warmly opposed factions
who could deftly sidestep the fray he
presses his lips the picture of caution
competence responsibilities like
Benjamin Franklin Watson was not born
into money nor did he started out with
connections both Franklin and Watson
were in many ways self-made thrown into
the work world and their teens
apprenticed in skills of the hand mostly
self educated both voracious readers
economists who rose early in the summer
to avail themselves of reading without
the expense of candles both men entered
the scientific arena as masters of
English written in a plain style
Benjamin Franklin and William Watson
were also at the time dubbed quote
associating men unquote joiners
networkers in the colonies for instance
a very youthful Benjamin had found his
way into the parlors of gentlemen
merchants who enjoyed his well-bred
conversations botanizing gave Watson his
foothold amongst upper people he did it
at the Royal Society and made himself
invaluable to men of rank and fortune he
would spend weekends as a guest that
their manners
advising them in their garden and he
brought his experience and encyclopedic
knowledge to the rare plants they had
acquired a great cost and it shipped in
along colonial trade routes with a
discerning eye Watson looked fray fakes
humbugs sort of like a curator Oh I'm
bagging a plan a curator opening up a
crate with a Rembrandt inside these were
expensive plants an electricity opened
up as a field of study Watson had
already established himself as a man to
be depended upon he was very well liked
he had become a member of the clique
sometimes called the jinto that met
behind the sacred veil at Roth mouths
the famous coffeehouse in near Covent
Garden favored by aristocrats for its
curtain seating watson also had another
entree into these social settings high
above his origins
it was razor sharp humour his essays
revealed the humorist he shared the
quality with Franklin though the humor
of these two scientists flowed in
different directions
there was a pointed edge to Watson's wit
always aimed in the other direction at
someone and Watson's laughter always
rang in chorus with associates
Franklin's humour was different his wit
could flash just as suddenly as Watson's
but often and very engaging ly at
himself his humor could be public or
private and when it was private Benjamin
would walk away poker-faced
never revealing his target
now Watson was enthroned at the Royal
Society meeting place which was had once
been a residential house at a little
tiny Lane in London called crane Court
it was a peaceful little dead-end street
not very long that opened on to Fleet
Street which was the noisiest
thoroughfare and broadest in all of
London it was just utter chaos out there
and so any refined gentleman when he
came to the Royal Society which was 2/3
bluebloods
because his carriage couldn't get down
that little lane had to get out right in
the midst of it all and it doesn't hurt
to see what London was like that it's
been said it was the first metropolis
people came from all over Europe to see
it like people might go to see the Grand
Canyon and I agree Falls there were so
many people there were so many people in
the streets of different social classes
and from different countries and the
gentleman as I said who had to get out
from behind their velvet curtains in
public descended briefly when they came
to these meetings and to bustle noise
and rudeness porters rocketing by on
foot chairmen shouting clearance for
their shilling a mild burden Shay after
Shay hurtling past the streaming of
foreign tourists just off the boat the
flooding of rural people displaced by
Mills the air babbling with European
tongues and mixing with the dialects of
Devonshire Derby and Lancashire and the
bawling of the street vendors the 18th
century visitor GC Lichtenberg reported
that if you name the great capitals of
Europe for the first words heard by
visitors London's name would be damn it
when electrical science came of age it
was part of this London story the sheer
intensity of its streets that drew
visitors from everywhere ranked with the
intensity and wonder of this new miracle
universal force electricity and it was
here that Watson found his name made his
name found his way into the Royal
Society and it was here Benjamin
Franklin's first letter came let's look
at Watson when this first letter came to
hand it would have been the summer of
1747 William Watson had just finished a
magnificent experiment that was drawing
praise across all of Europe he wanted to
test how fast electricity travelled and
he had set up an elaborate system that
summer of insulated wires he in fact one
of his experiments he crossed he sent it
across the TAM the Thames River and let
it come back through the waters to the
other side in an effort to gauge the
velocity he never did get a number to
put on it but everywhere people honored
him for this great effort and then he
came across this letter from nobody from
a colony at the edge of the wilderness
Watson now famous a celebrity who had
devoted a whole summer to performing one
grand orchestrated experiment and then
preparing to present his findings to the
Society at the end of October confronted
the unknown Franklin via letter a man
whose page pages gust with many
experiments and hints most of them
demonstrated by cork bits the size of a
child's marble
and then several months after comes the
moment that's going to set these crucial
events into motion oh and by the way I
did an intellectual theft occur back
then sure did but I think they had a
John to your attitude than we do about
everybody in publishing tossed in things
and I don't think they heard a copyright
at least in the way we had there were
some copyright things issues but anyway
the novelist Lawrence Stern has talked
about 18th century natural philosophers
claiming an idea and he makes an analogy
with a man out on a walk spying an apple
on the ground and picking it up when a
man in a state of nature picks up an
Apple said Stern and becomes his own and
I think the same thing happened in this
science Watson saw that letter and
here's what happened that day on the
darkening winter afternoon of January 21
17 48 William Watson arrived to Kirk
Crane court he had in hand his report in
it he would claim Franklin's three men
on two whacks Kate experiment for
himself
his friend is personal friend President
Martin Fuchs Esquire loomed over this
meeting on a huge carved wood throne
that had been commissioned by Sir Isaac
Newton long ago
Fuchs was quite a roaring boy himself
there's a picture of him by Hogarth at
the Royal Society and he's got all his
buttons undone and he's kind of giving
you this odd look and his fate is pink
his cheeks are pink I couldn't help it
mine folks he was quite a guy and when
he died he was known as a wonderful
writer and speech maker he took it all
and dumped it in the fireplace he didn't
want to shred the remain and it wasn't
he wasn't keeping secrets he just
cleared the deck when he left the planet
but anyway he's the man who was Watson's
close friend here at the Royal Society
the President and this is the day that
Watson is going to stand up and make his
claim some people have said why didn't a
member of the society leap up to protest
why not question Watson's claim but a
scholar Ellen Kufa pointed out to me as
I was researching this book I love this
quote Allen said when people don't know
what they're doing it's hard to
understand what they think they're doing
boy that talks about a lot of 1740s
electrical science but Watson stood up
and he was going at the nod from folks
he rose to his feet he plunged ahead
briskly reading aloud in the 8-inch
century style gripping the sheaf of
pages in his left hand and with his
right forefinger pressing his spectacles
tightly to his nose he starts out with a
few compliments and then he talks about
taking the liberties of reading
something from a letter he's received my
note liberties in the extreme at first
Watson's claim is we did this too
at the beginning of the quote the
Franklin letter according to Watson is
dated June 1 but after Watson finished
reading the quote from Franklin he
rolled on we contracted to I the claim
made for him snow self now expanded the
solution of this gentleman in relation
to this phenomenon so exactly
corresponds with that which I offered
early last spring that I could not help
communicating it he was claiming
priority he was claiming plus and minus
electricity that's the moment ah that's
that's the wheels going that in my view
led to the electrical kite thank you do
you have questions is things that
occurred to you as I read this it you'd
like to ask if you do that just step
over to the mine can
Tom what got you interested in this
topic when you first started very first
thing that sparked your interest
actually I had just when I just got done
with a book about children inventors
which I thought was written for middle
readers was based often on primary
sources had it had a chapter on Benjamin
Franklin so I grew interested in him and
I must confess that for a while I
thought of flying and electrical kite I
have repeated another Franklin
experiment and I kept reading him
carefully carefully carefully trying to
understand what he thought he was doing
and how he did it and then I noticed
something the 20th century's leading
science scholar who published the
standard edition of Franklin's
electrical science for some reason
although it was history used the fifth
edition published many decades later and
in a book I saw a facsimile of the
original announcement read to the Royal
Society and I noticed Franklin had cut
two things out for book publication
later and I asked myself why did he do
that one was a claim that what anyone
could do it and by the time he made that
change 1760 a man had died doing the
Franklin inspired lightning experiment
and the other was a mystery too he had
claimed originally that at that time his
invention or his genuine invention the
lightning rod had already been installed
on two public buildings in Philadelphia
and he took that out he never published
it in the local newspaper account he
didn't put it in the books and I began
to think wow why would he cook the books
and I shouldn't put it that harshly but
I began to look at it and things began
to unravel and it just didn't add up
that that was the scenario but what was
beneath was a much more interesting
scenario it was an adventure it was a
man who was a tradesman coming out of
nowhere trying to fight for recognition
for his electrical science abroad
it wasn't an easy battle and Franklin
used marvelous resources of intelligence
and humor I think in forwarding his
cause
Tom were you disappointed and some of
the things you found out in your
research and if so what disappointed in
what sense ah in Benjamin yeah maybe so
yeah
the editor from The New Yorker called me
up before he went to press with his
review and I was a little surprised
because that was his question well do
you feel different about Benjamin
Franklin now that how he told a lie and
I actually found Franklin the Franklin
behind the myth more interesting and
admirable exciting to read about than
the myth about myths there's something
very static you know you cut down the
cherry tree and you told the truth
are you threw a coin across the vast
river or you flew an electric kite but
the man who inspired that story York who
created it who nurtured it was himself
quite magnificent and to get in touch
with that in the book I think is for me
it was more fun than the initials tale
Tom would you speak some about the time
when Franklin came back to America after
having been in France you sort of teased
us there with saying that he had a
decade and a half left of his life did
he add much to the myth when he came
back to America now are you talking
about when he came back right before the
American Revolution at that point or in
his right that would later his return
from London he came back then he
expected in fact he expected to go back
to London the next fall he did not
realize the revolution was on the
horizon huh I don't think it I think his
gift at that point was knowing how to
keep his mouth shut and never
contradicting anybody and so he became
widely known as dr. Franklin and I honor
of his science and he accepted with a
wink that wonderful title I don't think
it was a battle at home at all he had
the Pennsylvania Academy of Science
which he had founded I think rather when
he came home there's more mysteries and
there ones I didn't have time to go in
to in my book but when he came home he
was a Royalist he was devoted to empire
I think what's another remarkable thing
about him and this may be answers the
earlier question a little bit - I came
to admire that someone so late in life
could change his opinion I don't know
many people that hit 60 and do 180
degree turn like that he came home a
conservative businessman and he stumbled
back across the Atlantic a revolutionary
I in danger of the hangman's noose so
that's a transformation that's a
transformation
I hope I didn't miss this in your
introduction because I was having
difficult time hearing everything but it
seems that Watson was mr. Franklin's
nimis and did Benjamin Franklin suppress
any feelings of resentment or animosity
or as a wise man he just ignored it in
and pressed on with his own philosophies
let me answer that I hope I don't drown
in my own footnotes Franklin's first
letters the ones that he revised for
publication include some insulting
references to Watson from the very start
I think Franklin had hoped to gain
notice at the Royal Society by making an
entrance confronting Watson and maybe
later he realized this was a bad choice
I was hired for Watson to look kindly on
pages in which he was being perhaps
sniffed at a little bit too at the same
time later on Franklin showed up in
London by that time electrical science
was done it was no longer the fashion
the craze and when he showed up neither
he nor Watson had any mileage to gain
out of arguing with each other over
electricity they were both shrewd men
and at that time Franklin was pursuing
other interest personal in public and
Watson was the same Watson became a
physician and became a physician to some
of the wealthiest and highest-ranking
people in the Empire and so I really
didn't believe them to get in a fight
but Franklin had better restraint than
Watson I did find one of Watson's
speeches delivered in 1762 he's
reviewing a letter from France and what
and he was a master coming down on both
sides of one line he was saying yes
there's arguments for the two-fluid
theory of electricity and France and
there's arguments for Franklin's one
fluid
theory and he said oh by the way I first
thought this up back in the spring of
1746 but then he went right back to
going on talking about the French letter
Franklin never fired a salvo back I
think he was too wise to get into that
ok this was almost like a mystery for
you to investigate um for your next
project are you going to do something
similar to investigate some something or
someone that you have to delve into a
little bit more thank you for that
lovely question you're absolutely right
there was a vein of it like exploring a
mystery and I had to pull myself back
from that because I didn't feel towards
Benjamin like a prosecuting attorney at
all and I didn't want to go that route
but I also had the thought that for my
next project I probably would write
about something totally
non-controversial I have in notes in
this book thicker than any my publisher
ever has had at the end of a book
because it's one that I think goes
against the established vision of
Franklin the standard one among scholars
and so that's really an issue when I
first went to Philadelphia to work at
the American foot I wasn't going to say
the library I went to a library and this
eminent archivist came up and I
introduced myself and started to talk to
him and the week before I had come out
and Entertainment Weekly that this book
had been signed was it was going to be
done Public Affairs books and the man
walked up to me and he said I know who
you are and I don't like what you're
doing at all
actually let me be fair to him we became
good friends he was very helpful we went
out at a drink at the end of the week
but what I'm saying is I sometimes think
about a second project maybe it'd be
nice to have one where there won't be
anybody who doesn't like what I'm doing
I wanted you to speak about the kite
experiment about the weather and what
you found out
oh goodness I wasn't gonna go too far
individuals okay but Diane and I flew a
replica kite there are many issues and
reasons why probably this kite then fly
one of the most recent hikes I got to I
don't know why I got to it quite late in
the book within the last year was this
if you're going to do Franklin's
experiment the whole point of it is to
get the kite up near thunder clouds
above you want that kite to be as high
as possible if you've ever flown a kite
if you want to fly it for distance and
send it out horizontally you let it out
if you want it to go up you pull it in
therefore when Franklin if he did fly
this kite underneath some kind of [ __ ]
or inside some window as his first
announcement suggested if you can
visualize here's the roof shed here's
Benjamin Franklin and here's this string
which has got to be as much toward him
as possible but there's a catch to all
this it's important that that string be
insulated that it not touch a shed and
later decades people who actually did
this experiment would record their
results were filed up if the string
blows against the shed or the window
frame you're out of business
the electrostatic charge drains away
and I had Diane hold up a picture frame
to be the window in this little
experiment in the parking lot so there I
was with my string and all this and
there was another factor too there was
the weight of the key which i theorize
the kite wasn't big enough to hold up it
would have drooped down there and you
had but you had to keep it dry so you
had to pull the rope even and closer to
you
and when I tried to do this out in the
parking lot I it was one of those
moments they happened other times too
but struggling with it it just came to
me he really didn't do this
any other questions
somebody habit malaprop's asked me why
did the French love him so much I don't
know it was one of those romances made
in the stars
perhaps but uh he was certainly a man of
great charm by the time he showed up
there he had his reputation as a thinker
who'd plumbed the mystery of lightning
and he plugged into all sorts of half
wrong theories they had about America
that said that they're half right - if
there's an image of in this all of
Franklin the unschooled teaching a
lesson to the school about lightning
there's also a bit of truth in it also
at the same time and I think the French
plugged into that
thank you very much I am I am very
grateful to have been here and talked
with you thank you